I'm going to be pointing to the board,
at least in theory,
I suppose I expect to be pointing to the board a little bit more today than
ordinarily.
Um,
so,
uh,
the,
the usual function of my,
my equivalent of PowerPoint isn't quite the same today because I'm taking an
interest in some of these diagrammatic matters as well.
Uh,
and as I say,
I will be,
I will be pointing to them.
All right.
So to begin,
I'm actually going to postpone something that you're probably already wondering
about,
although it will come in to this lecture on a couple of occasions.
That is to say the full relationship,
uh,
in terms of the influence of both movements between the Russian formalists,
and so serves notion of semiology and Santiago sticks until next week when we
discussed Roman Yacob sins,
essay,
linguistics and poetics,
where I think,
uh,
the relationship between the two movements in which he himself was involved,
will become clearer,
uh,
and will come into focus more naturally than if I tried to,
if I tried to outline what the connection between the two movements is now.
So that is an aspect of our sequence of lectures,
uh,
beginning with the last one,
that will be postponed until next week.
Now,
semiotics is not in itself a literary theory,
uh,
as we'll learn from the occupation next week,
literature can be understood or what he calls sort of the study of literature.
Poetics can be understood as a sub field of semiotics,
but semiotics is not in itself a literary theory.
In other words,
perhaps to your frustration,
what you read today has nothing at all in and of itself to tell you about
literature.
This isn't the last time this will happen during the course of the syllabus.
Uh,
but then of course our job is to bring out the implications for literature of
texts that we read,
um,
that don't have any direct bearing on literary study.
The important thing about,
so sir and the,
uh,
the discipline of semiotics is the incredible influence that had,
it has had on virtually every form of subsequent literary theory.
And that that's what we need to keep in mind.
A semiotics evolves into what is called structuralism,
which we will be considering next week.
Uh,
and that in turn,
um,
as it were bequeaths it's terminology and it set of issues and frameworks for
thinking to,
to deconstruction,
to a Lacanian psychoanalysis to French Marxism to binary theories of race,
colonization and gender.
In other words,
do a great deal that we will be studying subsequently on the syllabus.
So while again,
what we read for today is not in itself literary theory.
It is nevertheless crucially formative for a great many of the developments in
literary theory that we'll be studying now.
Just as a,
I don't know,
an anecdotal or conjectural aside,
I've always found it so fascinating.
I can never resist talking about it.
Um,
the relationship between various texts in our field,
history of criticism,
literary theory,
texts that are considered foundational,
which curiously enough,
I'll off Fuko,
don't actually have an author,
Aristotle's poetics.
Uh,
we know actually not to have been one of the texts written by Aristotle,
but rather to be a compendium of lecture notes put together by his students.
Uh,
and this is one of the reasons why,
uh,
in the golden age of Arabic scholarship in the Middle Ages,
there was so much dispute about the poetics,
the,
the manuscripts we find from this period of full of marginal notes where the
scholars are chiding each other and saying,
no,
no.
It can't be that way.
In other words,
in a way,
it's a disputed text and it is not a written by Aristotle.
It's a foundational text.
Um,
Aristotle is considered the father of criticism,
um,
and yet he is so as what Fuko would call a founder of discursivity.
Well,
the odd thing is it's exactly the same,
uh,
with,
so sir who can be considered the father or patriarch of a certain kind of
literary theory as I've just indicated.
So Sarah's course in general linguistics is not something written by so sewer,
but is a compendium of lecture notes written by his students in a series of
lectures that he gave from 1960 to 1911.
Um,
and then gathered together in book form,
uh,
by two of,
by two of his disciples who were linguists.
Now it's odd that we have that this text,
it does have the same formative function.
Scholars who go to Geneva,
uh,
go for a variety of reasons when they look at the socio or archive.
Some of them are predisposed to dislike.
So sir,
and to hope that they can somehow discredit him,
uh,
by learning more about things that he thought that aren't actually in the text,
others likeso sir,
and feel that he needs to be rescued from his compositors and yet others go,
uh,
in an attitude of worship and a hope that the archive will yield to them full
confirmation of the integrity of the text we call the course in general
linguistics,
uh,
there.
So that in a way,
the study,
the study of the socio archive,
given the volatile relationship of that archive with the actual texts that we
have,
um,
is,
uh,
a kind of map that if one were to study it,
one could associate with the history of thinking about literary theory in the
20th century.
This is really all neither here nor there.
I just find it interesting that two people who are incontestably Scott,
founders of discursivity and the field that we study,
uh,
are in fact not strictly speaking authors.
So now they're confirming the,
uh,
the insight of Fuko in the essay that we began by reading.
Anyway,
enough of that,
uh,
we have to try to figure out what so sewer is up to.
And,
uh,
let's,
and let's move on to begin to do so.
Semiology,
what is semiology?
It's the study of existing conventional communicated systems.
All of these systems we can call languages and language.
That is to say the words that we use when we speak to each other is one of those
systems,
other systems,
the gestures that mine's use.
Semaphores railroad,
semaphores a stoplight,
red,
green,
yellow is a semiotic system.
In other words,
all of them are modes of communication with which we function,
uh,
the intelligibility of which allows us to negotiate the worlds around us.
Semiotics has expanded into ev into every imaginable aspect of thought.
There is a,
there is a Darwinian semiotics understanding the relationships among species and
semiotic terms.
Uh,
there is in other words,
uh,
a semiotics of virtually every imaginable thing.
Understood as a language made up of a system of signs,
signs we'll be getting to in a minute.
But in the meantime,
it's important to understand what semiology actually is.
That's what it is now.
Um,
oh,
I meant to ask you,
how many of you did not bring a,
the passages that I sent to you by email last night.
All right,
we have them here.
Uh,
and there'll be passed around.
We have about 25 copies.
So don't take one if you don't need it.
I'm not going to pause.
I am going to be turning to the second passage on the sheet,
um,
in which,
uh,
something about the nature of these systems I think can be made clear.
Language says social media is a function of the speaker.
Now here of course he is talking about human language.
Human language is not a function of the speaker.
It is a product that is passively assimilated by the individual.
Now what does this mean?
The fact that human language is not my language.
That is to say the fact that it doesn't originate in me.
The fact that it's not for,
in other words,
by private language is of course a certain loss because it means that when I
speak,
when I use language in speech,
I'm using something that is not strictly my own,
it's conventional.
That is to say it belongs in the public sphere to all of us and there's a
perhaps a certain sort of romantic loss in that.
Wouldn't it be nice if language in some sense were my own,
but the incredible game which makes language something like at the object of
science that so Sarah is hoping to secure.
This is one of the things obviously that he has in common with the formalists
they incredible game is that if language is not private,
if it's not my own,
if it's not something that I can make up as I go along,
if in other words it is conventional belonging to all of us,
that's precisely what allows it to be communicated.
It is a system of signs and other words that we can make use of that we
recognize as signs precisely because the exist among us as something that can be
shared in common.
And so this then is the object of saucers attention as a linguist,
uh,
and as a semiotician
no.
What's implied and this idea is that language is something that we use.
I don't,
I mean the,
the,
the best way to say it and the quickest way to say it is that I don't speak
language.
Language is something that exists as an aggregate all at once,
arguably.
And this is something that's going to come up again as well.
And again,
as we come back to these coordinates that we'll be touching on from time to time
today,
also,
arguably language is something virtual.
You remember that Freud said,
we have to infer the unconscious from the erratic behavior of consciousness.
I mean,
there's gotta be something back there.
So we're going to call it the unconscious and we're going to try to describe it
very much the same with language.
Long as so Sarah calls it.
It sounds like,
I mean what we do is speak and when we speak,
of course we say correctly that we use language,
but we need to know what language is and we need to understand the relationship
between language and speech.
Now we can understand language as a kind of aggregate of everything that's in
the lexicon,
in the dictionary together with everything that would be in some sort of ideal
or utterly systematized a rule set of rules of grammar and syntax,
but there is no real aggregate of the aggregate of that kind.
In other words,
it exists.
It's there to be put together partly as a matter of experiment and partly as a
matter of conjecture by the linguists,
but as as a composite thing existing in a spacial simultaneity,
Sin Chronically
language is something that in a very real sense as is the case with Freud,
we infer from speech now speech is what we do.
Speech is the way in which we appropriate deploy and make use of language.
And so Sarah calls that pothole.
Powell is the unfolding in time of a set of possibilities given in space.
That set of possibilities being sort of being what a socio recalls long
now language is a system of signs.
What does a sign?
So Sarah's famous diagrams make it clear enough.
We have above the line a concept and we have below the line a sound image and
other words I think of something and that thinking or,
or,
and that thinking of something corresponds to a sound image that I have ready to
hand for it.
And that can be understood in terms of thinking of the concept tree.
That's why this is in quotation marks and I speak Latin and funk.
And,
and,
and knowing that the,
uh,
the sound image correlative to the concept tree is our board.
Right?
Or I can think of
something like that,
uh,
something hidden in some way resembling that.
And by the same token,
I still speak Latin.
Uh,
the sound image corresponding to it is our bore.
Now I'm going to,
I may or may not get back to this today,
but in this question,
mark is the secret of deconstruction.
All right,
just,
just do,
just to keep you poised and on tender hooks.
But in the meantime,
what so is doing with this relationship above and below the line is he's saying
that is an arbitrary relationship between the concept and the sound image.
The concept he calls a signified,
uh,
the sound image he calls a signifier,
assign,
in other words,
is made up of two sides in a,
as it were a thought moment.
The real a relationship between that which is signified and that which signifies
it,
add it,
add it.
And it's to be understood that we have to think of them together.
They're not divisible,
their relationship is necessary.
But as we'll see in a minute,
arbitrary and each sign is like that.
And the way in which we put signs together is to take these bundles,
these binary relationships between a concept and a sound image and adjust them
in an unfolding sequence.
That's how we speak.
That's how we make a sentence.
All right?
So
in a way,
the idea that a signifier us,
a sound that I make are bore refers to a concept.
And by implication,
by very powerful and strong and necessary application,
not do a thing
is not in itself new.
The idea that a word signifies an idea and not an object is already fully
developed.
And John Locke's essay on human understanding and is more or less commonly
agreed on ever afterwards and is as I say,
uh,
in itself a conventional thought that so sir adopt and makes you so,
but what is new?
And so sir,
and what really is foundational and the in semiotics as a science is two things
that,
so sir then goes on to say about the sign,
the first thing he has to say is that the signified signifier relationship,
as I said,
is arbitrary.
And the second thing he has to say as the way is that the way in which we know
one sign from another,
either studying it,
studying language and the aggregate whereby clusters of signs exist in
associational relation to each other or studying it in speech act in speech
whereby signs exist next to each other and a sequence,
the way in which we understand what a sign is,
is differential.
So that what's new and so soon was thinking about the relationship between
signified and signifier as the sign tied up in this relationship is both
arbitrary and differential.
Okay.
This is a first walk through some essential ideas.
I want to go back to the distinction between language and speech and refer you
to the first passage,
which now all of you have it on your sheet because
like the Russian formalists.
So Sir is
chiefly concerned and outlining what he means by semiology to establish the
Samuel logical project as a science.
And like the Russian formalists did in a way like the new critics talking about
their academic colleagues.
So sir is vexed by the messiness and lack of system in the study of linguistics.
And this is what he says in this first passage says,
if we study speech from several viewpoints simultaneously,
the object of linguistics appears to us as a confused mass of heterogeneous and
unrelated things.
This is speech of I'm,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a linguist and so what do I do?
I study speech,
I studied speeches and if I do so,
and if I keep thinking about it in a variety of ways,
all sorts of frameworks jostle for attention.
So Sir continues this procedure opens the door to several sciences,
psychology,
anthropology,
normative grammar philology and so on,
which are distinct from linguistics,
but which might claim speech in view of the faulty method of linguistics as one
of their objects.
As I see it,
there is only one solution to all the foregoing difficulties from the very
outset.
And this is her rotten peculiar mixed metaphor from the very outset.
We must put both feet on the ground of language and use language as the norm of
all the other manifestations of speech.
What's it's,
it's as if he's trying to hold language down,
stay there,
stay there.
We put both feet on the grounds of language so that we have it so that we
haven't so intelligible to us as a system,
as something that can be understood precisely differentially that can be
understood in the variety of ways,
uh,
in which,
language,
uh,
organizes.
It might be worth pausing over the variety of ways in which we can think of
signs in language,
all of which have to do with the way in which are given sign might be chosen to
go into a speech sentence.
Uh,
I don't know.
Take the word,
take the word ship.
A ship is very close to related and sound to certain other words.
We won't specify them for fear of a Freudian slip,
but they,
uh,
but,
but that is one cluster that is one association matrix or a network that one can
think of,
uh,
in the arrangement of that sign in language.
But there are also synonyms for ship,
bark,
boat,
Bateau,
a great many other synonyms,
sailboat,
whatever,
uh,
and they to exist,
in a cluster steam ship,
ocean liner.
In other words,
words that don't sound at all the same,
but they're contiguous in sin,
anonymity,
they cluster in that way.
And then furthermore,
ship is also the opposite of certain things and that,
so that it would also enter into a relationship with train,
car,
truck,
mule modes of transportation,
right?
And in all of these ways,
ship is clustered association,
Italy in language in ways that make it available to be chosen,
available to be chosen as appropriate for a certain semantic context that we try
to develop when we speak.
So that's the way that's that that's the way,
uh,
assign works in language.
I mean this is,
this is the tip of the iceberg for any given sign,
but it gives you some,
and,
and by the way,
uh,
and what I'm saying,
I oversimplified by supposing that the basic constituent of you,
unit of language is a word.
Linguist.
Know that that's not at all necessarily the case.
Linguists,
uh,
can work at different levels of abstraction with language.
I mean,
sometimes the basic unit is the phrase,
uh,
but some other times,
but the basic unit is the phoneme that is to say the single sound unit or if one
studying languages and system of writing,
it might be the syllable.
Uh,
it could be the letter understood either graphically or audibly.
Um,
and the variety of ways in which one can choose a basic unit in the study of
linguistics,
uh,
means that you need a special word for that unit,
which is characteristically the tag meme and other words,
whatever you w w what,
whatever your thinking of as you're systematizing understanding of language as
the basic constituent unit.
The word being probably one of the less popular choices,
even though that's the one I've just used,
it is the blanket term for that is the tag me.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you cannot,
you can understand the associate,
the association will nature of signs also as tag Munich.
Then of course,
um,
since uh,
there's a certain amount of sematic payoff,
let's say if you're talking about a phoneme,
uh,
especially because,
because of the,
uh,
the,
um,
as so sir we'll say,
and his,
I'll get back to misleading on amount of poetic drift of language.
Perhaps a certain sound has certain connotations,
meaning the sound may cluster,
uh,
as sort of in,
in and an associational network.
Um,
but depending on the unit chosen,
then the associational networks will differ,
but they will still exist as a matrix.
In other words,
it is always probably,
I mean,
how else,
how else could we have any sense of systematicity in language?
It is all was probably the case that when I speak,
I won't choose just any word.
Ee.
Cummings actually boldly experimented with this principle and,
and he attracted the attention of the linguists,
particularly a linguist named Del Himes.
Um,
he,
he hammock ee Cummings wrote sentences like he danced his did,
where did is obviously not a word you would have supposed to be in anyway
involved in an association.
They'll cluster in language,
you know,
I mean,
he danced,
his did.
That is in every sense,
um,
a misfire as the,
as,
as the,
uh,
as one school of thinking about language would call it a,
and yet at the same times,
Cummings thumbs his nose at us and deliberately uses that word almost as though
he were issuing a critique,
uh,
of semiotics,
but at the same time,
uh,
such that a semiotics would probably have available to it.
Uh,
it's,
it's ways and means of refutation.
I a certain amount of ingenuity is that's all,
all that's required to notice that uh,
Duh,
uh,
reiterate the d the duff sound in danced.
Uh,
and that there are all sorts of combinatory pressures on his consciousness to
choose did as opposed to some other seemingly irrelevant word.
But in any case,
um,
uh,
so,
so in any case,
you can still,
even with these egregious examples,
understood,
understand language even in its infinite variety.
Nevertheless,
as,
uh,
associational,
and as clustering,
it's available signs in ways that make them more readily to hand for choice,
then they might be,
um,
uh,
all other things being equal.
Well,
in any case,
so language is a system of signs.
The signs are both arbitrary and differential.
Now what does this mean?
This is actually the second thing maybe that we learn under the influence of
what we call literary theory and the thinking that surrounds it about the nature
of perception.
Okay.
If the sign is both arbitrary and differential,
that is to say if there is no such thing as a natural sign,
something that is linked by nature,
by the nature of the thing and the word together with a thing.
If on one side of the of the border as so Sarah puts it,
we look at a cow and say,
oh,
and if on the other side of the border we look at a cow and say birth and if we
cross a considerable body of water and we look at a cow and say,
cow,
uh,
plainly,
the relationship between the thing
and assign,
you know,
the,
the Matrix signifier and signified just doesn't exist.
So signs are arbitrary and they're also differential.
I have to be able to distinguish between all the signs I use in any
communicative sequence and how do I do it?
By putting in Zines,
which are not other signs,
the sign is not linked to the natural world by any natural means.
And the sign is not linked to other signs by any natural means.
I don't know,
a unit of language which I used to commute,
communicate with you positively.
I know it negatively.
I know it only because it is not everything else in,
in the terms of its direct relationship with the thing that's most adjacent to
it somehow either through similarity or dissimilarity,
it's not that other thing.
But generally speaking,
the point about a sign is that it's not any other thing.
This is true even of hominins.
This is true even of of of of seemingly identical signs because each has its use
value,
uh,
and,
and his only intelligible as it's that which it,
which exists to mean in a certain context.
So,
uh,
it is always the case that I can only know
what I know.
If it's a question of being communicated with having something rendered
intelligible for me negatively,
I can't know it because it just is either that sign or that is,
I don't know it positively I'm about to give,
I'm about to give an example of this,
which I hope which,
which I hope will flesh out what I'm trying to get across in the meantime.
A couple of passages in.
So sir,
ah,
that may make the point now not on this version of your sheet.
Uh,
but on the version,
the not on the version of the sheet that I passed out today,
but on the version that I sent electronically last night,
there's a fifth passage and that passage is actually a combination of
formulations of,
so sir that are on two separate that are in two separate parts of your texts.
The first one is on page eight 44.
Can this possibly be correct Tyson?
I hope it can.
Um,
uh,
no,
it is not correct.
It's page eight 45
the lower left hand column where,
so Sarah says language is a system of interdependent terms in which the value of
each term results solely from the simultaneous presence of the others.
As in the diagram just below it.
In other words,
the value of a term,
I say something the value of the term of I honor us out.
The value of that sound cannot be determined except by its context.
I can't know it except by the way in which it differs from everything that
surrounds it.
And he goes on to say,
this is on page eight,
47,
about halfway down the left hand column,
he goes on to say a segment of language can never,
and the final analysis,
the based on anything except it's non coincidence with the rest arbitrary and
differential are to correlative qualities.
Now why don't,
and then and then again,
um,
uh,
an another passage on page eight 46,
the right hand column,
halfway down concept are purely differential and defined not by their positive
content but negatively by their relations with other terms of the system.
Now probably this is hard to accept.
Intuitively we feel as we process the world around us that we know things for
and as what they are,
we feel,
you know,
I look at something and I know what it is,
forgetting that positively.
I only know what it is big print because of a context in which indeed it is not
those other things that are linked to it.
Now I want to take as I want to take an example.
Uh,
I could use any example,
but I'm going to use something which plainly does move around various semiotics
systems.
It's,
it's a piece of language,
but it also belongs to other sorts of semiotics system as will immediately see.
I want to use the example of the red light.
Now in a stoplight,
which is probably just about the simplest semiotic system that we have,
it only has three.
One is tempted to say variables,
uh,
plainly differing from each other.
Red,
yellow,
and green.
We have two ways of thinking about the red light.
If we think that our knowledge is positive,
we say red in a red light means stop.
It is spontaneous to us to say red light means stop.
Now,
if all we have to go on is just this semiotic system,
it's going to be kind of hard to put up resistance to that sort of thinking.
Because by the same token was say,
yellow means pause.
Green means go.
These do these three lights with their respective colors.
Just do positively mean these things.
Everybody knows it.
Uh,
and I'm certainly not thinking when I approach an intersection that,
uh,
when I went in,
the red light goes on.
I'm not saying to myself,
oh,
not yellow,
not green.
You know,
it's by my mind,
my mind just doesn't work that way.
All right.
But still,
it's a red light,
right?
And our hypothesis is that the red light has positive value in the sense that it
means a certain thing.
It means we say stop.
Well,
suppose the red light appeared on or as the nose of a reindeer
and that case,
the red light would be a beacon,
which means forward.
Go follow me.
Damn the torpedoes.
We've got to get these presence to script distributed,
no time,
no time to waste,
you know,
and we race off,
uh,
who perhaps risking in our accident,
who knows where we race off,
uh,
under the compulsion of the meaning of the red light,
which is go all right.
Now,
by the way,
there's an anecdote,
the truth of which I've never been able to ascertain that,
um,
during the cultural revolution in China,
Matt,
I'm now Madame Mau,
uh,
very much disapproved of the fact that red lights meant stop because red is of
course the color of progress.
Uh,
it ought to mean go forward,
uh,
and you know,
and,
and everything behind it.
Um,
but needless to say,
uh,
her thoughts on the subject were never implemented because if one day red light
means stop and the next day red light means go,
there might be a few problems.
And so,
um,
and,
and this by the way,
is a way of showing the,
the,
the fact that,
um,
that everything which appears in a semiotic system is conventional,
right?
I mean,
it is,
it,
there's an emptying out of positive meaning in the very awareness that after
all,
the red light could mean go.
I'm about to go on and give more examples.
Uh,
it's conventional,
whatever the convention is within a system of differences,
that's what makes the sign intelligible.
All right.
Just some other examples are red light over a street door.
Well that doesn't mean stop.
That means go in,
come in.
All right.
Uh,
it's an,
and of course it exists in a semiotic relationship to a white light over a
street door,
which means this is my house.
Um,
if you wish you can ring the bell,
but I just,
as soon you stayed out,
this light is probably on to keep burglars away.
Uh,
and so stop right and,
and,
and the,
and the red light is intelligible in other words,
within that,
within that semiotic system.
Now over an auditorium door.
And of course we've already been gazing at that light back there.
Uh,
and it's not a good example.
I wish it didn't say exit,
but it does say exit because that,
that's sort of,
that kind of weakens my point.
Um,
but,
but over many auditorium doors,
uh,
or red light just hangs there.
And obviously it doesn't mean come in and the sense of the red light over a
street door,
it means go out.
Right?
This is the way out.
This is the way you get out of here.
Not,
this is the way you get in here.
I mean there are a lot of,
there,
there are a lot of ways in which red light means neither stop nor go,
but we are sort of confining ourselves so far to the ways in which are red light
has something to do with locomotion or the lack thereof and in new system,
Nah,
no system.
You can see it takes on a new meaning always with respect to whatever it is not
all right now.
Uh,
well,
I mean we can continue on a light up.
Valentine means don't stop,
go.
You know,
it has this,
it has the same function.
In other words of negating,
it's on meaning in another semiotic system.
In this case,
the semiotics system of the stoplight
on an ambulance or a police car.
I admittedly,
many of these lights are blue these days.
But let's suppose,
let's suppose that you know,
tradition prevailing that there they are still red on an ambulance or a street
car.
They mean get out of the way or stop.
All right.
And other words.
In other words,
they probably bear a distant relation to the Santiago sticks of the stoplight.
And that's probably why red was chosen,
uh,
for ambulances and police cars because they put into your head the notion of
stop.
But it's a notion that's complicated in this case by the equally imperative
notion get out of the way,
which doesn't at all necessarily entails staffing,
but rather accelerating,
uh,
in a different direction.
Uh,
and,
and all of that somewhat what complicates the picture.
But at the same time,
I think you can see that there's a connection between those semiotic systems.
It's,
it's,
it's a weak system in terms of color and the case of ambulance and police car,
it's more a question of brightness.
As I say,
red tends to be chosen,
but then,
you know,
if you get lab experiments showing that that particular color of gas blue is
somehow or another,
you know,
sort of more invasive of your consciousness than red is,
then,
you know,
you move away from the arbitrariness of the choice of red as a color.
Um,
and as I say it,
there's a certain instability which,
which could never apply in the semiotics of the stoplight because there it's not
so much a question of the brightness of the color,
although that has been experimented with as you know,
um,
but rather the insistence that the color is just that color.
And then finally,
and here is where,
in a way,
this is perhaps the most interesting thing because,
because it forces us to show the complexity,
to see the complexity of semiotic relationships or red light,
just to return to the Christian holiday or red light on a Christmas tree.
Now our first thought is,
Oh Haha,
that has no meaning.
Right?
You know,
it's not,
it's no use talking about the negative relationship between a red light and a
green light and a yellow,
white,
blue,
whatever,
whatever the other colors on the Christmas tree are,
because they all have the same value.
They're all bright,
they're all cheerful,
they all say merry Christmas,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So what are you supposed to do with that?
Here you've got a red light,
which doesn't seem to enter into this sense of the arbitrary and differential.
Yeah,
well that's because it's actually not a gross constituent unit,
right.
Bright Lights as the gross constituent unit and the variety of those bright,
bright,
bright lights,
which is a matter of aesthetics.
Uh,
the variety of those bright lights is ironically enough neutralized by the
common signifier governing our understanding of them,
which is bright lights in this case,
particularly on a tree or festooning,
another ornament that has some sort of comparable value.
And once you get that,
once you got the value Christmas tree as opposed to red lights,
red lights being perhaps a part of some Christmas trees,
then you see that you're back in a semiotic system in a very obvious one because
a Christmas tree is a,
not Menorah,
a not kwanza candles,
a Christmas tree,
in other words,
is a sign that can only be understood intelligibly in terms of a certain
cultural understanding.
And we think,
of course,
ah,
you know,
I mean we know what that is and of course probably we do,
but were misled in supposing that that's the key to the understanding of it as a
sign because it's very possible to imagine a circumstance in which someone
wouldn't know what it was forcing us.
Despite it's familiarity,
it's familiarity to ask us,
well what is it and how do we know what it is?
And then we realize once again that we can only know what it is if we under,
if we come to understand in this case,
probably it's best to say a cultural system understood as a semiosis a cultural
system within which it appears.
And so this last version of the red light,
uh,
introduces interesting complications,
which I don't think should confuse.
I think they should actually show us a little bit more about how we can
understand,
uh,
the organization of the things around us and within us as systems of signs.
We know that we've already learned from Heidegger and the remanent of tradition
that we know them as something.
Okay.
But it remains to show how we know of him.
That is to say we don't know them positively.
I mean,
how do you get raises?
The interesting fact that we spontaneously recognize something
and that makes us and that,
but that's one of the things which could be dangerous for semiotics because it
would make us think or assume that we know them.
We know things positively without thinking.
In other words,
I know that that's an exit sign or I don't know that it's a white thing with red
marks on it.
I know that it's an exit sign,
but I can't know that the,
so sorry.
An argument is without knowing that it is not all the things that it's not.
If it were all the things that it's not,
or if it were identical to all the things that somehow or another it's not,
then I would be in a very different difficult situation because I wouldn't have
any means of knowing it in particular.
The very fact that I need to know it in particular is what makes me need to know
it negatively
and that is,
it seems to me.
In other words,
we now know two things about how we perceive things from this,
from the standpoint of this subject matter.
Uh,
and I,
and it's very useful to put them together.
The fact that we always know things first,
but at the same time,
the fact that it's misleading to think that that are knowing them first means
that we know them positively.
We know them first,
but we also know them negatively in negation to other things.
Okay.
So let me just return once again to the way in which science systems are
intelligible because you know,
I mean,
lots of,
there are we going to be lots of moments in a course like this in which what we
seem to be saying is it,
oh,
we can't know anything are we don't know what we know or how do we know what we
know and met and maybe we're,
maybe we're skirting a rhetorical questions of that kind,
but we're really not.
What we're talking about today is how we do know things that,
I mean that's,
I mean if we take,
if we take semiotic seriously,
it gives us a rather sophisticated means of understanding precisely how we know
things,
but it insists that we know things because of their conventional nature.
That is to say because they are conventions existing within a system of
conventions and so far as we don't recognize them,
things signs as existing because if we,
if we're thinking about a thing,
we're thinking about that thing as a sign and semiotics.
If we don't know that,
if we don't recognize it's existence in a system,
if we can't think what system it belongs to,
perhaps to put it in a better way,
that's tantamount to say we're really don't know what it is.
And I think the more we think about it,
the more we realized that we only know what it is if we know the system that it
belongs to,
which is to say all of the things related to it,
which it is not.
Right.
Okay.
So the intelligibility of sign systems is there.
Conventionality that's why it's impossible for anybody to come along and say,
oh,
I don't like the fact that the red light is red.
It's symbolically the wrong move.
Let's make the red light,
uh,
the symbol of go.
You know,
I mean,
you know,
with the ecological movement,
we've very difficult to make the green light,
the symbol of stop.
But in any case,
all,
all sorts of,
all sorts of complications would arise,
right?
But in the meantime,
you see that we can't mess with conventional systems by imposing the
individuality of our will on them and expecting anything to change.
A seeming a seeming exception
is the fact that sometimes individuals can buy it through the exertion of their
influence and prestige actually changed the way we speak about things.
This is a seeming exception.
Think about the way Jesse Jackson almost single handedly convinced us that we
should use the expression African American,
even though it's a cumbersome polysyllabic expression,
which you would think somehow or another would be intuitively rejected because
it's so hard to say.
But it worked.
He convinced us all to say African American and you say to yourself,
Aha,
there's an example of somebody taking language by the scruff of the neck and
changing it as an individual exerting the an individual will over against the
conventional nature of language.
The answer,
the said that the semi attrition's answer to this is it never could have
happened simply as an active agency as an act of will.
It had to be acquiesced in.
You needed the community that makes use of linguistic conventions to acquiesce
in a change of use.
Remember,
language exists synchronically.
It only exists in a moment,
in a moment of simultaneous simultaneity.
We study language Daya Chronically.
That is to say,
we study it's history.
We study.
It's unfolding in time.
Now this unfolding is not according to the semiotician and here's another link
with the rush and foremost is not a question is not a question of studying.
The way in which language has changed from without
that is to say studying the way in which,
for example,
an individual can rise up and insist on changing one of the signs,
but rather a see a sequence of sin,
chronic cross sections from moment to moment,
language changes.
But if we're to understand it as language,
we have to honor it's simultaneity.
And in that case we understand it as a sequence of cross sections rather than
something that somehow organically changes through time.
Uh,
and at each cross section,
people are either willing to use a certain sign in a certain way or they're not.
That's the crucial thing.
If they're not willing,
the use of the sign doesn't work,
which confirms the idea that nothing can be changed simply by individual agency
in and of its self.
All right.
I need to come back to synchrony and Diane Skrany.
I'll do so,
uh,
next time.
Uh,
and probably in subsequent lectures because we're going to keep using these
coordinates.
We're going to keep using the things that exist in space,
virtual or not,
and the things that unfold in time in their relationship with each other as we
continue to try to understand these basic principles,
which shaped so much of subsequent literary theory.
Thank you.